if you imagine the scenario that you are
in an office with lots of people here
you quite like but not enough don't
spend time and money on getting them an
individual gift a Secret Santa is the
perfect way around that because what you
do everybody puts their names into a hat
everyone picks a single name out of a
hat and you buy one crappy presence for
just one person in the office then
everyone gets to walk away with a crappy
present the important thing though about
sit your Center is kind of clues in the
name
it is supposed to be secret nobody is
supposed to know who boss anybody else
is present apart from the one that you
buy everything is completely anonymous
as a sort of a fundamental rule of the
secret Center agreement I guess it's so
you can get away with buying basically
junk other people I mean it always there
always crummy on it because people don't
really know you so it's always like bath
bubbles hooray
Oh like I don't know a book on numbers I
know that's Jay but yeah like an
encyclopedia of numbers you know yeah
exactly exactly or like you know visit
there's a guy he was a jogger for here
and every single time he always gets
something with a map on it just a
generic bland map because obviously he
must love maps I think there are two
fundamental things that you need for a
perfect suit your secret Center one
total anonymity and two everyone should
have an equal probability of being
selected by anybody else right there
kind of two fundamental things now the
normal way that you do this of everybody
writing their name down putting in a big
bowl and picking a name of a hat fails
on both of those fronts okay so imagine
you've got everybody who's involved in
your Secret Santa sitting around a table
everybody writes their own name onto a
piece of paper and drops it into a bowl
in the middle and then that bowl is
passed around the table and people pick
out names of who they're gonna buy the
gift for if they pull out their own name
though they read it and replace it back
in the bowl and then pick another name
by doing that you have to sort of
consider the situation where the last
person around the table picks out their
own name now if they do that
what how do you solve it without
violating the rule of anonymity because
they can't swap it with anyone else
because by doing so they would know
exactly who is buying them a present so
the only real fair thing to do in that
situation is to scrap whole thing start
all over again there's quite a good
chance of that happening so if you have
20 people sitting around your table
there's a 4% chance that the last person
will pour their own name and you have to
scrap and completely start all over
again if the second last person pulls
their name it's a third to last person
pulls their name you know all sorts of
anonymity issues can be violated the
chance of anybody pulling anybody else's
name is not uniform it depends on where
you're sitting around that table because
what you're looking for in this scenario
you are looking for something called a
derangement so it's a type of
permutation where nobody ends up with
their own name effectively okay so
imagine you've just got three people
playing you got a B and C now even
though there are six ways that this can
be reordered there are only two extra
permutations here that could work for
Secret Santa to derangements they're
called
so there are other permutations of
course but the problem is with any of
these three in every case somebody if
they're sitting around table in a b and
c somebody will end up with their own
name so this column here is kind of who
that person is pulling out so if a is
the first person on the table they're
going to pick their own name in this
permutation b will pick their own name
in this permutation and c will pick
their own name in that permutation so
none of those are allowed that none of
those are allowable Secret Santas the
question is how likely is it that each
of the people end up buying for a
particular person and it turns out that
the order that you're sitting around the
table makes a difference to that APICS
first then B goes second and C goes
third so if we think about the bowl of
names for a we know that if a picks out
their own name who's going to replace it
oh she think I'm gonna place it back in
the bowl so really there's only two
things that a can can pick out from that
bowl and the guess Secret Santa carry on
so that's either B or C and then the
probability of 1/2 in each case because
if they pick a it's a non game exactly
they they read their own name put it
back in the bowl and then pick again
okay so if a ends up picking out B now
it's B's go so B's already out of the
pile so there's only two names left and
either one that B can pick is totally
fine we're gonna pick a or C and each of
those has preventive a half however if a
is pick b and b is picked a there's only
one name left for c to pick from which
is their own name and that my friend is
a fail there's a failed secret center
which means the only fair thing to do if
you want to preserve everyone lives is
start all over again from scratch put
your names back in their hat and then
start from the beginning if instead he
ends up picking C then we're okay
there's only one name left in the hat
and that is a's name and that's actually
fine and that's got a probability of
happening of one so that's if they ended
up picking B in the first place if a is
up picking C you can still work this
through but there's less going on in
this case there's any two nodes s in hat
is B and a B can't pick themselves if
they did they'd read it they'd put it
back which means that B really only has
one name that they can pick out and the
secret santa continue which has to be a
and that's gonna happen from ability the
one which means now once you get to see
there's only one name in the Hat and
it's B's name which also happens with
probability of one okay so now you've
got these this one failure one
absolutely find arrangement that works
to secure Center a and another one here
but you could work out the probabilities
of each of these happening if you kind
of travel down these arms of the tree
this permutation here of C a B which we
have up here some here this one is going
to happen with the probability of 1/2
because it's 1/2 times 1 times 1 this
one here this this other successful arm
of BC a is gonna happen with the
probability of 1/2 times 1/2 which is
1/4 and then the other branch of this if
you like is a failure so you're also
gonna fail with the probability of 1/4
which means that a is much more likely
to end up buying
see than they are for being so even
though they're they're just as likely to
pull out the second person's name as
they have a third person's name if they
pull out the second person's name half
of the time the whole thing will then
fail so I have to start over from
scratch so what you end up with in this
situation is not only the chance of
failure and having to start all over
again but you also end up with a
situation which isn't perfectly random
you don't have an equal chance of
fighting for other people in the office
so if I was sitting in a row of three
and I'm the last picker I know
it's most likely that the first picker
is buying me a present
yeah it's twice as likely that the first
Pickers buying a present there's a
second picker which might help you when
you try and decide where to sit around
table because yeah you don't want like
some person who's rubbish at presents to
be buying for you so the exact
probabilities change depending on how
many people you have but the overall
idea is the same that the probability of
you buying for a person later on if you
go first is different to the probability
of you buying for somebody you're on the
tree so overall I mean I think this
version of Secret Santas pretty rubbish
really it's got two massive problems
with it so what you could do if you
wanted you wait until everyone's got a
name it was picked a name out of a hat
and that's when you look at it and
that's when you decide if if somebody's
got their own name you call the failure
and you start all over again
unfortunately that one's got a fish ten
percent chance of failing and a five
percent chance of failing more than
three times in a row by which time I
think people are gonna be less keen to
buy each other presents and maybe just
want to call your day however we've got
a solution we've got a secret santa
system that it does actually like okay
what do you do now if you want the
perfect Secret Santa setup you create a
series of cards the cards are kind of
split in two and at the top of the card
you write you
four and on the bottom the card be right
ye buying number four say whatever the
number is on top the same number is on
bottom so you do lots of cards you do
one for each person so if you've got
twenty people you write twenty cards if
you've got three people you write three
cards you get all of these cards you're
laying on a table shuffle them all round
so you have no idea what order they're
in and then when you're happy that
they're neatly shuffled you go along
with a pair of scissors and cut the
cards into so now you have no idea what
cards are next to each other and you're
kind of cutting along the line and
there's scissors that everyone draws in
school how do they do them like that
they go it's not great you go along and
you cut them all up now at that point
you can create your derangement and you
can do that just by shifting the top
half of all of the cards along by one by
doing that you're guaranteeing that the
number on the top of the card isn't
going to match the number on the bottom
of the card so you've definitely got an
arrangement definitely got a secret Sun
system that works but also because you
shove with them you have no idea what
numbers are matching with the port
numbers so the next step everybody who's
playing in secret Center comes along
picks up a new whole card so top and
bottom half that are now matched up
together say you pick one up and it says
you are number three and you're buying
for number 27 then the final thing that
happens is that you write a list of all
of the numbers put it on the wall of the
office or whatever everyone then comes
along they know what number they are
because the car that they've picked up
will have told them and then they come
along and then they write their name
everyone now knows their own number they
know the person they're buying for but
they have no idea who else is buying for
anyone else in the secret Sun system and
everyone has an equal chance of buying
for everybody else I mean there is a
final way that you could do this
specifically which is just to go online
and use one of the free apps but this is
much nice but it's fun gotta be hats and
tickets and pulling cards and things
yeah I agree
this is traditional way non-computer way
let me ask you this mathematician
hello have you ever done this nope I'm
famously stingy when it comes to buying
Christmas presents away get involved if
you're in the market for some gifts and
Hannah hasn't put me off the idea of a
mathematics book these are books that
she's written
you could try them out I'll put links in
the description along with links to some
numberphile merchandise you could try
like t-shirts and posters and if you
want to see more of Hannah besides here
on numberphile why not check out her
recent guest appearance on objectivity
links for that as well